you may know that it takes light a zippy
eight minutes to reach us from the
surface of the Sun so how long do you
think it takes light to travel from the
Sun's core to its surface a few seconds
or a minute at most well oddly enough
the answer is many thousands of years
here's why photons are produced by the
nuclear reactions deep in the core of
our Sun as the photons flow out of the
core they interact with matter and lose
energy becoming longer wavelength forms
of light they start out as gamma rays in
the core but end up as x-rays
ultraviolet or visible light as they
near the surface however that journey is
neither simple nor direct upon being
born each photon travels at a speed of
300,000 kilometers per second
until it collides with a proton and is
diverted in another direction acting
like a bullet ricocheting off of every
charged particle it strikes the question
of how far this photon gets from the
center of the Sun after each collision
is known as the random walk problem the
answer is given by this formula distance
equals step size times the square root
of the number of steps so if you were
taking a random walk from your front
door with a 1 meter stride each second
it would take you a million steps and 11
days just to travel one kilometer so
then how long does it take for a photon
generated in the center of the Sun to
reach you we know the mass of the Sun
and can use that to calculate the number
of protons within it let's assume for a
second that all the sun's protons are
evenly spread out making the average
distance between them about 1 times 10
to the negative 10th power meters to
random walk the 690,000 kilometers from
the core to the solar surface
then require three point nine times ten
to the 37th power
steps giving a total travel time of 400
billion years that can't be right the
Sun is only 4.6 billion years old so
what went wrong two things the Sun isn't
actually of uniform density and photons
will miss quite a few protons between
every collision in actuality a photons
energy which changes over the course of
its journey determines how likely it is
to interact with a proton on the density
question our models show that the Sun
has a hot core where the fusion
reactions occur surrounding that is the
radiative zone followed by the
convective zone which extends all the
way to the surface the material in the
core is much denser than wet while the
hot plasma near the surface is a million
times less dense with a continuum of
densities in between and here's the
photon energy relationship for a photon
that carries a small amount of energy a
proton is effectively huge and it's much
more likely to cause the photon to
ricochet and for a high-energy photon
the opposite is true
protons are effectively tiny photons
start off at very high energies compared
to when they're finally radiated from
the sun's surface now when we use a
computer and a sophisticated solar
interior model to calculate the random
walk equation with these changing
quantities it spits out the following
number 170,000 years
future discoveries about the Sun may
refine this for
but for now to the best of our
understanding the light that's hitting
your eyes today spent one hundred and
seventy thousand years pinballing its
way towards the sun's surface plus eight
miniscule minutes in space in other
words that photon began its journey to
ice ages ago around the same time when
humans first started wearing clothes